cette rencontre impromptue entre le
président de la cftc les membres du
syndicat sud libre en fin de matinée en
dit long sur le climat qui règne dans
l'entreprise dans le jour ce matin dans
le rapport de l'inspecteur du travail
remis aux délégués syndicaux étaient
clairement notifié la levée d'une
modèles et les actions que vous avez
commencé à entreprendre et qui
continueront avec l'arrivée des
techniciens devant intervenir me
permettent de lever le doigt d'alert
émis par le chsct
après l' enquête faite par
l'inspecteur la semaine dernière il a il
a vu examiner les situations de travail
il a vu avec l'employeur sur les
situations de travail où il y avait un
danger grave et imminent les mesures à
prendre et à partir du moment où les
mesures donc il pouvait être prise
rapidement sont prises le droit de
reprise donc à la modification du
rapport de l'inspecteur du travail
l'anc est faite le 15 novembre par
l'inspecteur du travail a permis de
constater les anomalies qui ô justifié
un doigt de la laërt
elles vont de l'absence d'étanchéité
dans plusieurs bus à des défaillances
techniques dans des véhicules et des
distributeurs de titres de transport les
engagements de pallier les
dysfonctionnements pris par la direction
ont conclu à la levée du doigt d' alerte
mais pour les partenaires sociaux il
n'est pas question de baisser la garde
doit-il pas encore levé il faut que la
direction s'explique sur les réparations
des véhicules ainsi que les
distributeurs automatiques fait un
calendrier pour voir comment on peut
réparer les véhicules
vous avez des voyants qui s'allument
rouge de manière réguliers sur la
direction à donner comme principe c'est
de passer la valise effacer le défaut et
le problème est réglé
si bien que nous avons déjà eu trois
véhicules qui ont pris feu sur place ils
ont du travail
le président de la cftc elle lui
s'appuie sur le doigt et met en garde
les salariés
nous avons prévu
que la reprise se fasse puisque le nez
specter indique que le doigt d'alert
élevé dans les conditions du droit
maintenant les gens qui veulent camper
sur leurs positions se positionne
autrement et là il y aura effectivement
péril peut être à la fois pour
l'entreprise mais tout simplement pour
les contrats de travail des uns et des
autres il faut bien le comprendre
on ne peut pas faire à fond perdu ce
sont les deniers publics qui paye
quelle tournure prendra ce bras de fer
entre direction et salariés
ce conflit pourrait évoluer sur le
terrain judiciaire en attendant dixième
jour son bus et sans tcsp
les usagers sont exaspérés